KEVIN LU: On behalf of talks
at Google and the black Googler
network, it is my honor to
present Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
Just a quick introduction, in
case you're in the wrong room,
he is a six-time NBA champion
and a six-time MVP award
winner.
In addition, Kareem is
a best-selling author
and the global culture
ambassador for the United
States of America.
Thank you for coming.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Nice to be here.
Thank you.
KEVIN LU: I think everyone
here knows how great you
are at basketball.
What they might not know is
that you are a huge baseball
fan too.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Yes, I am.
KEVIN LU: Did you ever
try to play or go pro?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
I did try to play.
I played up through
Little League.
I also played in the
seventh and eighth grade.
You know, after
you're 12 years old,
you don't play in Little League.
And I play for my
grammar school.
I went to school
in New York City.
And I really had
talent as a pitcher.
No one worked with me
on the issue of control.
So some my pitches went up
into the fence and stuff.
And basketball was just
so much easier for me.
So I decided I'd stick with what
was working real good for me
at that point.
I had already one a
scholarship to high school
and got better than
that very quickly.
So I gave up my aspirations.
I didn't have-- what's
his name-- I always forget
his name at the wrong time.
KEVIN LU: Randy Johnson?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Yeah.
KEVIN LU: Big Unit.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
The Big Unit.
KEVIN LU: Yes.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
There we go.
I didn't have him
as a role model.
My role model was Don Drysdale.
Not a bad one, but the Big Unit,
at 6'11" and throwing a ball
like that-- they put the gun on
me when I was in eighth grade,
and I was throwing the
ball over 90 miles an hour,
but nobody knew where
it was going to go.
Some of the parents would
come and watch me pitch,
and they were like, get
my child out of there.
He's going to kill him.
So I stuck to basketball, and
everybody was happy with that.
But I was a Brooklyn Dodger fan.
I've been a Dodger
fan my whole life.
Jackie Robinson and
those guys were my heroes
when I was a kid.
When I left New York, when
I left Brooklyn, I cried.
My mom had to console me.
I was 10 years
old at that point.
And then eight years later, I
followed them to Los Angeles.
So that's my baseball stuff.
KEVIN LU: Speaking
of Jackie Robinson,
he was also very
politically active.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Yes, he was.
KEVIN LU: Did that
influence you?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: It
influenced me a lot, especially
the stuff he did
after he retired.
You know, he started
a bank in Harlem.
And I went down there with my
$34 and put it in the bank.
I just really thought that what
he was doing about awareness
really made a lot of sense.
And I really appreciated
what he was doing.
KEVIN LU: Who were
your other role models?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Jeez, my
other role models-- Dr. King,
Malcolm X are two
that stand out,
especially at that time,
when I was in grade
school and high school.
And a lot of musicians-- my
dad was a jazz musician who
could not-- his dream was
to be in Count Basie's band.
He never made that.
So you know, he was
a police officer.
But music was a big deal for me.
And Miles Davis-- really,
I admired his style.
I admired his music and what
he was about politically,
about being able to be
recognized for his creativity
and what he was doing to
create America's only art
form that is totally American.
That really resonates with
me, and I enjoyed that,
and I enjoy his music.
I knew a number of
the guys in the band.
Two of them are still alive--
Herbie Hancock and Ron Carter.
Ron used to play basketball
with me and my boys
when I was in grade
school and high school.
I didn't know who he was.
He was just one
of the older guys
that wanted to play with us.
And then I realized, you're
playing in Miles' band?
Oh my god.
So I got to meet the rest of the
guys-- Wayne Shorter and Tony
Williams.
I met Miles.
It was weird, though,
meeting Miles.
The first time I met
Miles was at a jazz
festival in Orange County.
I was a freshman at UCLA.
And Tony and Ron
introduced me to him.
And he said, look at this guy.
He has to pay $500
to get a tie made.
And then he walked away.
This is not really how you dream
of meeting one of your heroes,
how you want that to go.
So two years later,
after we had won
the NCAA tournament-- Miles
watched a lot of sports.
He liked basketball.
He like boxing-- but
then he knew who I was.
And I ran into him in
the street in Harlem,
and he was like
Kareem, oh my god.
He took me to his house.
We watched some fight films.
And it was amazing to go
from somebody that he just
made a weird joke
about to somebody
that he invited into his home,
and we had a good interaction.
It was amazing.
KEVIN LU: So what motivated
you to write this book?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
I'm worried about what's
happening in America.
We're supposed to be trying to
make this a more perfect union.
And it seems like we've
lost our connection
with what the founding
fathers had in mind.
And basically,
that's what motivates
me to write what I wrote.
I think that we're
starting to understand
some of the implications of
what the founding fathers--
who they were as
people, and what
their intellectual emphasis was.
In order to make it
a more perfect union,
they're going to
have to get away
from some of the ideas that
supported white supremacy.
When our country
started, slavery
was part and parcel of it.
Women couldn't vote.
Native Americans couldn't vote.
There were no other
people than Europeans.
And that's changed dramatically.
And we have a big
disparity in, if you
look at the legal
system, people of color
are given much greater
sentences, bigger fines,
more punishment
for the same crimes
that white people commit.
But white people get
less time, less fines,
and stuff like that.
And it's a bias that
we've all accepted,
and we can't accept that.
So we have to do something to
change that and make the laws
work for everybody.
And if we can do that, we're
going to accomplish a lot
and actually make this
a more perfect union.
KEVIN LU: So despite
having a black president,
institutional racism is
still a problem today.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Yes.
KEVIN LU: What can
we do about it?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well,
I think one of the issues
about having a black
president, everybody
thought it was a sign that
said the end of the road
has been reached.
We have a black president now.
Americans are able
to judge someone
on the basis of his
intelligence and what
he saw as a vision of what
America should be about,
and they elected
him based on that.
And everybody really
got behind it.
I remember seeing in 2008, when
Obama finally made it over top
and got elected, and
they showed some film
of people on 125th
Street in Manhattan--
my hometown, my neighborhood.
And they were going
nuts on 125th Street.
Everybody was
jumping up in the air
and running around,
because, see,
it was easy to believe that
we had crossed the line,
and that we were all equal.
It's not a reality.
It was a milepost-- a
significant milepost,
but we still have a
long way to go, just
like what Dr. King said about
the things that needed to be
accomplished after he passed.
And I think we need to focus
on some of those things--
economic equality and making the
criminal justice system really
work for everybody.
KEVIN LU: In the
book, you also talk
about something called
wallpaper racism, in addition
to institutional racism.
What is that?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well,
wallpaper racism is just
the acceptance of stereotypes.
We believe that all the
police are not biased,
and they treat
everybody equally,
and they wouldn't
commit any crimes.
Police are just
like anybody else.
And some of them are good.
Some of them are bad.
Some of them try to
get away with stuff.
So we have to really eliminate
those types of things
that we accept just
because it's part
of the tradition of our country.
KEVIN LU: Well,
at Google we have
a lot of training to
try to get rid of bias.
And diversity is a very hot
topic in tech right now.
And you have a
Skyhook Foundation
that promotes STEM education.
How does that work?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, what we
do-- I work with the Los
Angeles Unified School District,
and we take kids
from the inner city.
KEVIN LU: I think
we're good now.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Are you sure?
It could be Ming the Merciless.
We take kids from inner
city, and we send them
to a camp for five
days and four nights.
And they do a hands
on STEM experiments
in the field at a camp that
the Los Angeles Unified School
District has up in the
Angeles National Forest.
It's just north of LA.
You can see it from LA.
A lot of the kids can see
it and have never been.
They've never really
left the circumstances
of their own neighborhoods.
So we get them up
there, and we get
them to deal with
things, usually animals
and observations.
They do nighttime
observations of the sky
and get an idea of how
technology affects their lives
and how technology affects where
the good job opportunities are
going to be in the 21st century.
And they get this
idea, and they go back.
We do it for kids up through
junior high school, because we
found that after
junior high school,
97% of females and 92% of
males give up on anything
having to do with technology.
If you get to them
early enough, we
can affect that and
give them an idea
of where they can do a great
job in finding a good career
in a technological field.
So this has had a
really profound effect,
because we found that
a lot of the kids
have family members
who work in hospitals
and other technologically
sophisticated places.
They are nurses aides
or lab technicians,
and stuff like that.
And they start to get
a better idea of what
they can do with their lives.
So many kids want to be LeBron
James or Beyonce or Jay-Z
or these kind of people.
And they have no
chance of doing that.
But if they pay attention in
chemistry class and math class,
they can really take that
and make a career out of it
and do very well for themselves.
So we've done about
80,000 students so far.
We have a three or
four-year waiting list.
And it has put me
on kind of a path
where I have to keep begging
for money and more funding,
because so many
more of the schools
want to come and
become involved.
It's had a very, very positive
effect on the kids that
have been able to take part.
KEVIN LU: Do you want
to plug the website.
I'm sure some Googlers
would love to donate.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Oh,
KareemAbdulJabbar.com.
Just go to
KareemAbdulJabbar.com,
and you'll will find out how to
make a donation to the Skyhook
Foundation.
And before you even call, I want
to thank you for your support,
if you feel like supporting us.
KEVIN LU: What do you
think of the diversity
programs in the corporations?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I'm
glad that corporations
are seeing the need
for diversity programs.
You know, the whole idea of
bringing women and minorities
into parity with the people who
traditionally do well, I think,
is incredible.
It's necessary.
This is part of
what has to change
before we make the progress
that we need to make.
KEVIN LU: Well, this is related.
Why do you think
we need to see more
minorities on TV and in movies?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, I think
that the fact that you
see more minorities
on TV and in the movies
means that you're not
shock to see somebody
that doesn't look
like you doing something
that you didn't
think that they could do.
For the longest time, there
were no black quarterbacks
because it was
too intellectually
challenging for black
people to take the snap
and throw the football.
Absurd stuff, but
this was accepted.
It was too intellectually
challenging for a black person
to pitch.
Don Newcombe and people like
that changed their minds
on that.
But it took a while.
So we're still
trying to overcome
some of the stereotypes that
we just take for granted
and accept.
And it's amazing
how much of a hold
they have on our
way of thinking.
It's amazing to
me, because there
have been to many objective
examples of how that is not
true, and it doesn't work.
But the people
still hold on to it.
KEVIN LU: I think we made
Warren Moon improve himself
for seven years in Canada before
letting him back in America.
That's pretty awful.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Warren had the arm,
and he had the intellect to be
a pretty good NFL quarterback.
KEVIN LU: Speaking of
other people on TV,
Serena Williams is playing in
the US Open Semifinals today.
How awesome is she?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I
think she's quite awesome.
And she's done a
little bit better
than people like Jimmy
Connors and John McEnroe.
And that's hard for people
to get their head around.
But she has.
And she pays a
price for it still.
She doesn't get the endorsements
and other opportunities that
have nothing to do with tennis
that other tennis players get,
just because they are
pretty white women.
KEVIN LU: Do you want
to expand on that?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: No, I
think that's enough said.
KEVIN LU: All right.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
I don't have anything
against pretty
white women, but I
think Serena needs to
get her chance too.
KEVIN LU: You're also a
huge advocate for equal pay.
Why is that important?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Oh,
it's absolutely important
that we bring the pay
of women up to par.
They do their share of
the work, but they don't
get their share of the pay.
There's something that
stinks about that.
And we need to do
something about that.
And I hope if
Hillary gets elected
that she helps speed that
along, because again it's
maintaining a stereotype
that women do not
have the intellect
or the tenacity
to be in leadership positions.
That has been disproven.
Benazir Bhutto and
Golda Meir have
proven that to be a falsehood.
But that nobody wants
to acknowledge that.
So we just have to keep
pushing on that one.
KEVIN LU: In the
book, you also mention
that we also need to address
the issues facing lower income
women and women of color.
What are their
specific challenges?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well,
I think lower income women
and women of color have to
lead single-parent homes.
And then they need more help,
because if their kids do not
get the educational
opportunities that they
need to do well,
they're going to become
a permanent underclass.
So we need to do
something about that.
We need to remedy that
situation and make it possible
for them to be effective
parents, because they're
carrying a very heavy load.
KEVIN LU: Well, why don't a lot
Americans care about the poor?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Most Americans
don't care about the poor
because most Americans don't
want to be poor.
And they see so many examples of
people who come here very poor,
and they make it.
Andrew Carnegie--
very poor person--
I think his family were
sheepherders in Scotland.
They came here, and they
did they did all right.
And for certain
reasons, if you have
white skin and good business
ideas, you get the opportunity.
If you don't have white skin
and still have the good business
ideas, you'll either get
ripped off for your ideas
and not paid, or
you'll be ignored.
So that has to change.
KEVIN LU: Actually,
I really appreciate
that the book mentions 10%
of Americans in poverty
are Asian-American.
That's not a fact a lot of
people know or care about.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
They don't care about it.
And again, we're dealing
with a stereotype.
Most Asian-Americans come
here, and they open up
a Chinese laundry, and
they make all this money
and buy some real estate and
sell it and make billions,
and they're living
down in Florida.
KEVIN LU: Wait.
That pays more than Google?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: They
have tremendous wealth,
and they're living in Florida.
And they don't have
to work anymore.
That's all BS.
They work hard for
what they get, just
like any other ethnic group.
KEVIN LU: The next question--
it's also related to income.
Should we pay our
college athletes?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
We absolutely
should pay our college athletes.
They're being ripped off.
They make all this money.
The guy who runs the NCAA makes
$6 or $7 million a year to.
The athletes who put that money
on the table make nothing.
They get room and board
and tuition, and that's it.
There was a gentleman that I
knew when I was going to UCLA.
He explained that to me.
He said, in the three years that
UCLA won the NCAA tournament--
no offense to the Huskies,
please-- but in those three
years, UCLA made millions off
of you, and what did you get?
I didn't get anything from them.
I got a couple hundred
dollars each month.
And he said, that
that's not right.
You're like an unpaid
minor league for the NBA.
So we need to change
the situation.
So we would get season tickets.
All the players
got season tickets.
You get two tickets.
And the face value of those
tickets was for $400 or $500.
He scalped my tickets for
me and got me about $3,000.
And that enabled me to at
least take my girlfriend out
to dinner and to have a car.
I'm not saying that we have to
make college athletes wealthy.
But we should pay
the people that
earn the lion's share of the
money, which are the basketball
teams and the football teams.
They're the ones that
there's so much support for.
And they supply the
bulk of the money.
I mean, nobody pays money to
go see the water polo team.
And you know they work
just as hard as the guys
on the football team
and the basketball team,
but it's not a
revenue-generating type
of event.
So I think they
need to find a way
to judiciously and
fairly spread that around
for all of the athletes
that work so hard
and make the people that
support the universities proud.
KEVIN LU: So right now, we don't
have our athletes in college.
And we don't let the ones
who are professional athletes
speak their minds.
What do you think of Colin
Kaepernick right now?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well, I
think Colin has the right idea.
He should use his
position as a platform.
But I think he has to be a
little bit wiser about what
he's advocating.
He was going to try to portray
all of the police departments
as pigs.
That's not good.
He's defeating his own purpose.
But if he can get
to the point where
he gets a dialogue going between
communities and their police
forces, and they want
to heal the divide
and really make it so that
the police have an idea of who
the people are that they're
there to protect and serve,
and the people in the
community have an idea of what
the police are doing
to keep them safe,
when we get that mutual
appreciation of each other,
that's when a bridge
has been built.
And sports heroes can really
pursue facilitate that.
So I'm going to talk to the
guys on the Seahawks today
later on this afternoon.
When we were talking
to them, they
wanted to talk to me
about these issues.
And I intend to bring
this up and help
them get an idea of how
they can do it wisely,
where they don't
alienate everybody,
because the people
that have worked
so hard in our country,
especially police officers,
they don't appreciate
being smeared
like that with a broad brush.
But there are some
bad cops out there.
But that is not really
what it should be about.
It should be about
making it better
and finding a way to train the
police better, so that they
don't react to the
fears that they have,
because they have
legitimate fears.
Police work is a dangerous job.
They know that.
But sometimes it
gets out of hand
and their reactions are
totally inappropriate,
and people end up dying.
And that's the real
shame of all this.
So we're going to
find a way to get
them to understand
that and hopefully
build some bridges with the
various police agencies,
because all cops love
sports, because it's
a great diversion for them.
They've got to go out
and risk their lives,
oftentimes on a daily basis.
So we got to appreciate that.
And if we build
this communication
and make that possible, I think
it will be a great improvement.
KEVIN LU: You have
been politically
active ever since your
playing days at UCLA.
Didn't you boycott the 1968 Ol--
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
'68 Olympics, yeah/
KEVIN LU: That was
in Mexico City?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
It was in Mexico City.
There wasn't really a boycott,
but I didn't go anyway.
I didn't want to go.
The person who ran the
US Olympic Committee
was named Avery Brundage.
And he was the
individual who did not
let the Jewish athletes compete
in Berlin in 1936, because it
was going to make Hitler angry.
So I wasn't going to
do anything for him.
That was out.
So I didn't go.
That's why I didn't go.
I didn't make a
big stink about it.
I just wasn't going.
But I think that Tommie
Smith and John Carlos really
did it in a way that got the
point across without offending
the wrong people.
KEVIN LU: But did you
still get any backlash?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I
got a lot of backlash,
because people thought
that I secretly
was a communist or some
type of subversive.
And my own tendency to keep
quiet and be shy really
didn't serve me very well.
I needed to speak
up and let people
know what my thinking was
all about, because I think
a lot of them would have agreed
with me on a lot of the issues.
But I had a lot to learn.
KEVIN LU: How about the
time you demonstrated
after the assassination of
Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well,
after Dr. King was assassinated,
I took part in a demonstration
on UCLA's campus.
And we just stood on the campus.
We didn't say anything.
But some of us had signs.
And a number of people--
about four or five people--
stopped and said, hey,
you're getting an opportunity
to play in the NBA.
What are you doing out
here demonstrating?
And they didn't
understand the fact
that the two had no
relationship to each other.
I was talking about the
unnecessary and horrific
assassination of a great leader.
And they were talking
about the fact
that a black athlete had
the nerve to protest that.
It was just a total
miscommunication.
But I dealt with it.
It didn't last that long.
But it was something that
really opened my eyes
to how stereotypes and people's
thoughts about the way America
is could be so distorted.
And they had no
appreciation for the reality
that we were dealing with.
KEVIN LU: Wasn't your very first
article about Dr. King too?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Jeez, I don't remember.
It's so long ago.
KEVIN LU: There's a
section in the book that
talks about how you were a
student or amateur reporter
at a King's r--
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Oh, OK.
I was in high school.
KEVIN LU: Oh, wow.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Yeah,
I was in high school,
and we had a program in Harlem.
It was a mentoring program
and also a summer jobs program
with different workshops.
And what it was all about was
to show the kids in Harlem
that they had to have an idea
of what their careers should be
and how they could make
Harlem a better place.
So I was in a
journalism workshop,
because I had aspirations
at that time to write.
So Dr. King came and
addressed all the participants
in the program, because the star
of the program, Dr. John Henry
Clarke, was friends
with Dr. King.
And Dr. Clark was a
sociologist and historian,
a very, very well known,
very highly respected person.
And Dr. King was
happy to address us.
So they gave me, as someone
in our journalism workshop,
press credentials.
And I went covered it
with the people from CBS
and "The New York Times"
with all these people
I'd seen on TV doing the news.
And I'm standing there with
my recorder and my notepad.
And I even got to ask
Dr. King a question.
And just having
him touch my life
like that-- he
answered my question--
I was like, wow and covered it.
And it's been part
of what has made
me motivated my whole life.
KEVIN LU: You've also written
books on the Harlem Renaissance
and African inventors
and decorated
black soldiers of World War II.
Why do you like history so much?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I like
history so much, especially
black American history, because
black American history is
part of American history,
but it's been marginalized.
And black Americans
have contributed so much
to what makes America the
great place that it is.
I start with even
the exploration
of the Western
hemisphere, which blacks
participated in, the
exploration of North
America, the Revolutionary War.
I try to give a broad
picture, so that black kids
could have something that
they could relate to,
a book that they could
open up and find out
how they fit in--
where do we fit in--
because American
history has always
been about white Americans,
what they have done.
And everybody else has been
marginalized, along with women.
And it has to stop.
If we're going to
paint that picture,
we've got to put everybody
in it that belongs in it.
So that's what that's all about.
KEVIN LU: The book also
dedicates an entire chapter
to aging and senior citizens.
What are some of the
challenges that they face?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, senior citizens also
are marginalized,
because they are
seen as being useless
and over the hill.
And they're not.
So many of the elderly Americans
still have great ideas.
And their wisdom and experience
are very, very useful
for those of us who don't
want to make mistakes.
So we need to appreciate
our older citizens
and not marginalize them and
say that they're useless.
KEVIN LU: You have accomplished
so much in your life.
How do you want
to be remembered?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, I want
to be remembered as someone
who cared about my country.
And if my kids can remember
me in a positive light,
I'm happy with that.
Nothing else is important to Me
KEVIN LU: Well, I think
that's a great answer.
And with that, let's open
the floor to questions
from the audience.
We have a microphone
stand over here.
So please line up and ask
a question if you have one.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, welcome to Google.
I think we covered that already,
but it's cool to see here.
We're honored.
As someone from a
different generation,
I've been really encouraged by
the level of dialogue that's
going on in our country
now around issues
of race and racial
equality, but I've also
been really discouraged
by the tone of it.
Having been through
different civil movements,
what do you think
of the general tone?
Are you encouraged?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I'm
encouraged, in so far
as people of color are
starting to understand
that they need to do something
so that they can be included.
I'm discouraged when
people want to support
the idea of white privilege.
That has been part of what the
problems have all been about.
People of color quite often
have been the last hired
and the first fired.
And that has been
wrong the whole time.
Qualified people do
not get the opportunity
because they don't look right.
I remember they were complaining
about an ad in North Carolina
during the race that
Michael Jordan didn't
want to participate.
And one of the people
running for office
had an ad that showed
black hands handling money.
And that really was
like a dog whistle
that we don't want black people
having any responsibility.
We just want them to be
here for menial hard labor
and to accept that and
keep their mouth shut.
So I think that that's
what it's all about.
We have to make this
a real meritocracy,
where people colored
and women are
able to benefit for what they
contribute to our society.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thank you.
KAREEM ABDUL JABBAR:
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: And also, I was
doing some homework for you.
Doug Baldwin of the Seattle
Seahawks just tweeted out about
an hour ago, "to express
a desire to bring people
together, our team will
honor the country and flag
in a pre-game demonstration of
unity." so just a heads up--
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: --when you
go talk to them later.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
And that's what I want.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm very
excited to be here.
Let me just open by saying,
unlike most people, perhaps
my first introduction
to you was actually
through "The Game of
Death" and Bruce Lee, one
of my favorite human beings.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
And he went to UW.
AUDIENCE: He did?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Yes.
KEVIN LU: And I learned
more about you from there.
I'm going to be presumptuous
and talk for just 30 seconds
about myself.
I think the
background's relevant.
No, it is.
I promise.
My dad worked in the
civil rights movement,
briefly, in Harlem.
I grew up in a black
neighborhood just outside
of DC.
I went to a public school that
was 90% black and 7% Latino.
I was picked on
for being the only
white kid in a 42-person class.
When I was 16, I was
stopped and frisked
and mistreated by
police officers
for being in a
poor neighborhood.
When my now wife,
then girlfriend,
gave me $1 for the bus,
it was called a drug deal.
So I put up against a
lamp post and frisked.
And my eyes started
slowly opening
to how much that was
happening in that neighborhood
to everybody, who, of course,
were are all people of color,
unlike me.
And then in college
I saw Tim Wise speak.
This is, again,
background story.
And Tim Wise is a white man
who talks a lot about race.
But he was very
influential for me,
because I've had these
moments of slowly waking up
to these issues.
But he was the first
person who came
from my background of having
experienced privilege and very
little forms of
prejudice in his life
but was so passionate
about the issue
and spoke from a background that
was easier for me to relate to.
But I was very
prepared, in some sense,
based on a lot of
experiences I had in my life
that were unusual for, I
think, white straight males
like myself.
And so I'm curious,
how much have
you talked to people
about, specifically,
this issue of making
these issues more
accessible to people who are
often not directly suffering
from the artifacts of oppression
and racism in this country?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Well,
thank you for your question.
I think that issue
is so important,
because in our country
it seems like it's OK
if there are a group
of people, and it
doesn't matter what
color they are,
if someone is in there
that is the wrong color--
and you went through that.
You were the wrong color
in a bunch of predominantly
African-Americans,
and you got picked on.
And that was seen as OK.
And it's not OK.
Just as it's never OK that black
Americans and other Americans
of color are picked
on when they're
the only one amongst a
lot of white Americans.
We've got to treat
everybody, as Dr. King said,
based on who they are and the
content of their character
and who they are, what
they are standing up for.
And we have to stand
up for people who
stand up for the right things.
And we can't have the
blinders on that blind us
to a person's character.
And sometimes color
can be those blinders.
So we've got to find a way
to remove those and reward
the people who deserve to
be rewarded and discipline
the people who deserve
to be disciplined.
And you can't be
biased about that.
We can't do that.
But we've permitted that
for so long that it's
become acceptable behavior,
given the right circumstances.
Well, there's a white guy
with all these black people.
Well, he's probably
a drug dealer.
Or he's married
to a black woman,
or he's something that the
traditional white society would
not accept.
And that goes both ways.
AUDIENCE: Oh, for sure.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Just as a very
brief follow up to that,
I guess the main
concern that I have
that I see regularly
is when we have
these conversations about
race, diversity, prejudice,
all of these things, there
tends to be two camps--
the people who
already understand
that there's a problem
and are actively
trying to be participants.
And then there are
people like I once was,
who were just very blind to
the issues in the first place.
And I came from this
background where
I feel that I was a little
more prepared to open
my eyes to see these issues.
But I also went to
college with a bunch
of-- all the white people
I knew in college came
from much richer families
than I did, grew up in totally
different neighborhoods.
And they just didn't
see this stuff at all,
didn't recognize it.
And I want to know,
how do we actually
start bringing these issues
to people who are not already
converts, part of the choir?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
I think the only way
I can do that is to get
these people who don't see it
because it hasn't touched their
lives-- we got to figure out
a way to get them
to see that issue,
because that's the issue.
Ignorance often is bliss.
Everything's great.
I got everything I need.
These people don't know
what they're doing.
They don't work hard enough.
They're lazy.
And that's not what
it's all about.
But until we can point that
out in ways that they get it,
we're going to have a hell
of an educational problem
to overcome.
But this is something
we've got to work on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Thank you.
I appreciate your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so
first of all, I want
to say thank you for
taking the time out
of your day to come
here and talk to us
and impart your knowledge on us.
I have a question that
has to deal a little bit
with wallpaper racism.
So I tutor middle school
and high school students
with Solid Ground.
So these are all
underprivileged children, mostly
children of color.
And what you see is that
when they go to school,
they have lowered expectations
from their teachers, it seems.
And apart from your teachers and
the people that are helping you
there, usually you get these
expectations from your parents.
But they don't always have
a great family structure
for that.
Often times, the child will have
parents that neither of them
graduated high school,
and they don't really care
about their child's education.
And so I guess, what
are your suggestions
for helping put expectations on
them so that they can succeed?
Because what I see
is that when they
don't have the expectations,
they don't typically succeed.
And when they do
have expectations,
they do succeed, because they
are almost always smart enough
to do what they need to do.
No one's telling them they are.
I
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, I think
the problem that
you're identifying
has to do-- the lowered
expectations are often
accompanied by teachers
who see lowered
expectations in the poor
kids that they teach.
So they use the discipline
issue to try and deal
with that to get
them to do something
instead of giving
them the opportunity
to overcome the gap.
So if their parents
don't have an education
and don't see that
as important, you
can still transfer the
values that you have that
enabled you to get to the
position where you are.
You can transfer
that to the kids.
They don't have to be
like their parents.
But so many times, people just
think it's a genetic thing,
and that's it.
And some of the brightest
people in our country
come from absolutely
horrible circumstances.
And they overcome it just
because they're bright,
and they recognize their own
ambition, and they go for it.
So I think that you can't ever
have an attitude where you
won't be pleasantly surprised.
You've got to allow for
that to happen as a teacher.
And if we can get that
idea across to the people
in power that make all these
things happen or not happen,
I think we can do a better job.
But raising people up
from poverty and ignorance
is really a very tough thing.
And it also would
require that people
are willing to spend money
to get the good teachers who
don't want to be involved
in it because they're not
appreciated, and they're
underpaid, and why bother?
I think we've gotten
to this point.
The American education
system, for so long,
was the best in the world.
Our high school students
had the best grades
of all the industrialized
countries in the world.
And now we're down 6th or 7th
place, 8th, 9th, 10th place,
just because people
aren't going to spend
the money for the good teachers
and give them the opportunity
to do the things that they
have done so well for decades.
Sometime in the '70s or '80s,
they just threw their hands up
and said, forget it.
And I think we paid
a price for that.
So I hope that changes.
AUDIENCE: I agree.
Thank you.
KAREEM ABDUL JABBAR: Thank
you for your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so in the
introduction to your book,
you mention how it's
really unfortunate
that often times
people repeat history
and the mistakes of history.
But my question--
what I'm wondering--
is why something that's
worked in history
hasn't been repeated,
and that's your signature
move, the skyhook?
Why, today, do we not see
that as much in the NBA?
I mean, obviously,
it's very hard.
I've tried to incorporate
it in my game, and I can't.
But I'm sure if I had more
time, I could perfect it.
Is it just that it's hard,
or maybe today the game's
changed, where people are going
for and-ones and three-point
plays?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Thank
you for your question.
It's not that hard.
I think what's happening is that
the guys who are teaching kids
to play the game--
kids, they don't
want to work with their
back to the basket,
close to the hoop,
where, actually, you
get a high percentage shot.
They don't want to do.
That they want to
shoot three-pointers.
Everybody wants to
They see Stephen Curry.
They say, oh, that's
what I want to do.
And when I was
learning the game,
guys that taught young
kids showed them post moves
as part of the game.
I had to learn post
moves, and I had
to try to learn how to
play perimeter stuff,
just so I understood the game.
And that's not happening now.
And everybody wants to
shoot three-pointers now.
I'm the leading scorer
in the NBA, all-time,
I made one three-pointer
in my whole career.
And I can tell you that was a
shock and surprise to everybody
that was there that night.
But the ball bounced
out to the corner.
I went out and got the rebound.
And there was nobody coming
to guard me or anything,
so I stepped back and shot one.
And went in fortunately.
I'm 1 for 13 in my
career in three-pointers.
But I took a lot of
high percentage shots
at the paint using my shot.
And it worked.
But kids, they don't want
to work on learning it.
So I think styles go in cycles.
So maybe at some
point, people will
realize that getting
high percentage shots
actually balances
out the guys that
can make the three-pointers.
And that's what you need.
You need you need versatility
on the basketball court,
because if you are stuck at
just making three pointers,
you're going to end up
like the Warriors ended up
this year, where once
Cleveland figured it out,
they shut them out on the
inside, got all the rebounds,
limited them to one shot.
They won three games in a row
to win the world championship.
And that was just because Bogut
didn't play for the Warriors.
They had nobody that could
compete near the basket.
And Cleveland's
eyes actually really
won that series for them,
despite the wonderful stuff
that you see from
Curry and Thompson.
It just didn't work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'll keep that in mind.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
You're welcome.
Good luck.
Good luck in the gym.
KEVIN LU: We just
have a few minutes
left for the rest
of the questions.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I
want to say I really admire
a lot of your op-eds and
writings about issues of racism
and a lot of these institutional
problems that we see today.
And I have two questions.
One is more on your
experience, and the second
is kind of advice.
So I grew up in a predominately
black neighborhood,
and I am what I call the
post-9/11 generation.
I was born Muslim, and
I was raised in the US.
And I was seven years
old when 9/11 happened.
And this kind of ties
into my question.
First, how has your
experience been living,
I guess, as a double
minority, being a Muslim
and an African-American?
And two, for people like
myself, for younger folks who
have kind of lived and grew up
with this experience of having
this kind of tax on expectations
of their behavior or things
they have, or stereotypes, or
anything they have to put up
with, how do you cope with it?
What advice do you have to
make it easier to deal with?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
OK, I've been
through part of
the same experience
as you have, because prior
to 9/11, being Muslim,
you kind of went
under the radar.
People weren't that
interested in it,
as long as you
didn't bother them,
they weren't going
to bother you.
Americans are
pretty good at that.
I don't know whether he's
about-- he has purple hair,
and he wear shorts and sneakers,
and they'll let you go.
But then, if you start
creating a problem,
you're going to get a lot
of negative attention.
And that's what happened.
I think for the
Muslim community,
they're going to have to engage.
They're going to
have to do everything
they can to show Americans
that they are just
as happy to be here as
all the other Americans.
Most Muslims are really
happy to be here,
because if they were
over in the Middle East,
or wherever that their
families came from,
they would have to deal with
some type of oppression,
either political oppression or
sometimes religious oppression,
because that is
commonplace over there.
And their wives and
daughters and sisters
get totally abused living
in that circumstance, when
the Koran says that
women are supposed
to be able to choose their
husbands, petition for divorce,
own and inherit property,
and that they are partners
with their husbands.
That's ignored in
the Islamic world.
That doesn't happen.
Women have no protection
there, and the Koran
says that those rights are
supposed to be protected.
Yet those Muslim governments do
nothing to protect the women,
because they enjoy chauvinism.
So most Muslim families are
happy to be here, especially
the women, because their
rights will be protected.
If somebody tries to
rape them, or if somebody
tries to force them to marry
somebody, they can protest.
And if they can prove
that to a police officer,
they'll get protected.
And that doesn't
happen over there.
So it's a failure, on one hand,
of these Muslim governments.
And sometimes it's a failure of
their families and communities
to engage.
But when Muslims
engage and let people
know what the Koran is about
and how they are supposed
to interact with other faiths
and how they're supposed
to be good citizens, no
matter where they live,
if they live in a
Muslim-majority country
or as minorities,
they're supposed
to uphold the laws
of the country.
As long as the laws of where
they live do not oppress us,
we're supposed to cooperate
and respect those laws
and respect the traditions
of that country.
That's what the prophet said.
That's what the Koran says.
So we just have to
let them what's right
and what's wrong in
these circumstances.
And you can change that.
And it all involves engagement.
So just have people not
be intimidated by it,
but explain who they
are, what they are about,
and offer their help to
overcome these things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
You're welcome.
KEVIN LU: Hey, we're running
a little over on time.
Let's just take this
as the last question.
And then one more.
You were standing in
line the whole time.
Is that OK?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: It's fine.
AUDIENCE: I'll be brief then.
I wanted to follow
up with something
you said about the election
of the first black president,
which to be sure is a
great barrier to cross,
but also doesn't mean
that racism is over.
And also, I think if you
look at the Obama presidency,
I don't know that he has
taken on the problems that
face minorities in America,
especially strongly, be
it racist drug policy
and incarceration rates
or deportation.
And I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit more
about what it has changed to
have young black people see
a black president and
what it hasn't changed?
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR:
Well, I think just
seeing a black president
for the last eight years--
and he's tried to
do so many thingg--
I think that that has been
great for the whole country,
black kids and white
kids, in so far as, hey,
he has his strengths
and weaknesses.
We can judge him on
those things and not
on the color of his skin.
And that's a big improvement.
But I think President
Obama had to deal
with so much opposition
from the Republicans
just because he
was a black person,
and he whipped them twice.
And they can't stand that.
That's really what
it's all about.
They can't stand the
way that he beat them.
He was smarter than they were
and understood the issues
and did a better job in
addressing the American people
about the things
that concerned them,
and the Republicans haven't
been able to do that.
They keep coming up with the
same BS about trickle-down.
We take taxes off of
the wealthiest people,
and jobs will trickle down.
That hasn't happened ever.
And they keep repeating this.
And it's horse crap you know.
So they've used that as an
excuse to oppose everything
that he's tried to do.
And it's really
hamstrung his presidency.
And in addition to
that, he has to be
present for all Americans.
He can't just be the
president for black Americans
and just someone in the
job for white Americans.
He has to do the best job
he can for all Americans
and can't be seen
as being biased.
And I think that, really, is
what you're talking about,
where he could have been
more proactive for issues
that are important to
minority communities.
But if he did that, the
majority of the country
would feel that he was
misusing his position.
And you know he was really
handcuffed in that sense.
But I'm so happy
that he got the job.
And did what he has tried.
And I hope that
people, over time,
will appreciate him more,
just for the patience
that he showed in
all this opposition.
We can't even get another
Supreme Court Justice
in because they don't want
to give him the opportunity
because he might do something
that they don't like.
And he did win that
election in 2012
that enabled him to do that,
whether they like it or not.
But they're not going
to acknowledge that.
It's really the
double standard that
applies to most people of
color that has traditionally
been part of the
American way of life.
And we got to get away from it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: Thank
you for the question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I'll try to make my setup short.
This touches on
themes-- you mentioned
that we need to solve the
problem of income inequality
and wealth inequality.
And some of the
previous questioners
also brought up the
ideas of visibility,
that people who are not
experiencing oppression,
even if they're
well-intentioned,
may not be aware
of its existence
and may think that
some of the people who
are speaking about it are
blowing it out proportion
and that kind of stuff.
So because of that,
I think some issues
that come up that
are very important,
things like affirmative
action and reparations,
you see people classify
that as reverse racism
and that we have this sort
of myth of color blindness
that everybody-- I guess
if they don't experience
the un-level playing field of
lack of opportunities a lot
of people are experiencing,
they think it sort of propagates
these myths of if people
just worked harder,
they would get the things
that my parents had
to work hard to get.
So I guess the specific
question I was wondering
is if you have a position,
specifically, on reparations,
whether you think
that's something
that our government should be--
KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR: I
don't think that reparations
are appropriate, because
there's nobody alive now
that owned slaves.
Those people, they
got away with that.
So there's nothing
we can do about that.
But I think that because,
especially people of color,
are so economically far behind,
that an educational effort
focused on the communities
of people of color
to get them to the point
where they can compete
for good jobs and
economic opportunities--
I think people
could accept that,
because these people
have inherited
an inferior position
economically for something
that they didn't do.
And it can be remedied
through education.
Their kids will have the
education and the opportunity
to do much better and
have some catch up.
But there's nothing we can do
about what happened in 1845.
There's nothing we
can do about that.
And I don't feel that I
can hold any white person
responsible for that.
It just doesn't work.
I'm glad people like
Georgetown University
are acknowledging
their culpability
and doing something about it.
And again, they're going to
have some scholarships for kids
from black neighborhoods
that need it to give them
the educational opportunity that
will enable them to overcome
something that they inherited.
So I think that's
the only way to go
about it without being unfair.
And I hope overall, throughout
the communities in our country,
we start to see that and
make the adjustments.
Thank you for you question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KEVIN LU: A quick
announcement-- you
can get a copy of
the book in the back,
and Kareem will be signing them.
And with that, let's
thank our guest.
[APPLAUSE]